So with just days left in their session before
the holiday break, that is upcoming, Democrats
and Republicans in Congress are reportedly
getting closer to a second coronavirus stimulus
package, a relief bill, as they're often called,
finally at the end of December.
They are closer, but nothing is yet guaranteed.
And I don't actually know what's worse, that
it's taken seven months to get close to a
second deal or what would actually be in this
deal, which we found out about over the last
24 to 48 hours, because this is a deal that
will include ungodly amounts of money for
many industries.
And it might include it might include 600
dollar direct payments for some Americans.
Now the information is changing regularly.
One estimate was it might be 900 dollars for
some Americans, 600 is the number that AOC
and others are talking about.
But the last estimate is it will be a 900
billion dollar total package with the possibility
of 600 dollars in direct payments to Americans.
And in the meantime, it would include that
blanket liability shield for companies against
coronavirus related lawsuits.
That's something Donald Trump has been talking
about after the first stimulus package, when
discussion of the second one started.
Donald Trump at every opportunity would say,
we want the liability shield for companies
and they understand what this is.
A lie, a coronaviruses liability shield for
companies means that if there is an employee
or a customer that gets the virus because
of how your business handled social distancing
and and sanitary guidelines, et cetera, you
have blanket protection from being sued for
that.
And it is essentially just an open door to
companies to do whatever you can to increase
profitability in the short run with no regard
whatsoever to the danger that you may be placing
your employees or customers or both in as
a result of ignoring guidelines which may
make you more profitable.
It's that that would be in there.
But they're battling for 600 dollar payments
for individuals.
The package, again, as of the latest iteration
that we've seen reporting on it, would not
include any assistance to state and local
governments, which is sort of where you need
to start to properly manage the different
ways in which this is affecting different
municipalities and states.
So it's just so pitiful and embarrassing and
pathetic.
There's really no other way to say know.
Six hundred dollars.
Some people received twelve hundred back in
May, plus those six hundred dollars a week
boosts in unemployment for people who were
laid off.
It's been seven months since that with nothing.
Who knows even if this is approved.
And that's a question mark, how quickly the
money would actually be distributed and make
it into people's bank accounts.
And they're talking about maybe six hundred
dollars.
Democrats proposed doing another twelve hundred
and they've been proposing that since May.
That went nowhere.
Some of the more progressive Democrats, including
friend of the show who we spoke to not that
long ago, Congressman Roxana, have proposed
two thousand dollars.
Some have proposed two thousand dollars per
month.
That's all going nowhere very, very quickly.
And the reality is, you know, I never want
to scoff at anything when we know that half
the country can't meet an unexpected 400 dollar
expense.
You see the number six hundred and you say,
well, that's we shouldn't scoff at that.
OK, but the reality is that 600 dollars, if
you're doing fine, doesn't change really anything.
And if you're if you've not been doing fine
since May, then what six hundred dollars going
to do materially.
I get it.
You know, maybe this makes it so you can make
half your rent payment next month and that's
better than nothing.
But it's not about beggars can't be choosers.
It's that the argument over whether we give
600 or 900 dollars to people after seven months
of nothing, given the economic situation,
communicates a complete lack of understanding
as to what's actually going on in the United
States for tens of millions of Americans right
now, even the first stimulus with the twelve
hundred dollars, it's fine.
And it was useful for people.
But if you were employed at that time and
you were continuing to work to earn a living,
the twelve hundred dollars was not likely
to affect your viability financially over
the course of the entire pandemic.
And that's why stopping short would that and
then going seven months with nothing is delusional.
What really was the life saver for a lot of
people back in April May was the enhanced
unemployment of an extra six hundred dollars
a week, which, by the way, in large cities
particularly.
If you have even just one child, it's barely
enough to get by without working, and in some
cities it's not enough to get by and look
at how many businesses were closed at that
time.
So this is a great example of how being cheap
is really expensive.
And we've talked before.
There's there was an interesting article I
recommended.
It must have been a year ago, maybe 10 months
ago, about how being poor is really expensive.
And the article explained, you know, if you're
poor, you're likely going you're more likely
to go to the bodega on the corner to get four
rolls of toilet paper rather than ordering
the 60 rolls from Amazon, which are better
quality and cheaper on a per roll basis.
But you've got to lay out some larger amount
of money upfront.
And in that sense, it's much more expensive
to be poor because you're often buying items
at a higher unit cost, sometimes of lower
quality and spending more time acquiring those
items because you're making multiple trips
instead.
If you go on Amazon and you get the big box
of toilet paper, it's an example.
The way it applies here is it actually applies
to a lot of consumer products.
You buy the really cheap work boots this year
and you probably have to buy another pair
next year and another pair next year or you
get and that gets really expensive in the
long run.
Or you buy the really good boots with the
lifetime warranty.
You do have to spend more now, but your long
term cost is lower.
The way it applies to stimulus is you do twelve
hundred bucks in May and maybe 600 now.
And it sounds like you're saving a lot of
money relative to giving people 1500 dollars
a month, two thousand dollars a month.
Sounds like you're saving money, but when
you consider that the cash payments are demand
side stimulus and they stimulate the economy,
plus higher long term payments allow people
to stay home and be more responsible, which
slows the spread.
And we know that every person who ends up
in the hospital for Carone with coronavirus
places a huge financial cost on the system.
You realize the higher outlay is cheaper in
the long term by suppressing the spread.
And case in point, you look at European countries
that are only in their second spike.
Now, that entire summer period in the northern
hemisphere where they had relatively normal
summers economically, was much better than
what we've had here where we are now on our
third peak, we had peak number two during
the summer and it was disastrous for business
and the economy as we continued to hemorrhage
jobs.
So that's a long way of saying one of the
richest countries in the world, which some
love to say is the greatest country in the
world, whatever that means, finds billions
for corporations in certain industries.
And we're arguing about six hundred dollars
for people.
It's pathetic.
Canada did two grand a month for seven months.
If you were working, but didn't earn very
much, you qualified, at least for part of
that.
Some provinces even did additional payments.
So what Congresswoman Pelosi and some others
are saying is if you don't find the six hundred
dollars appropriate, get in touch now with
your elected officials and tell them that.
But really more is needed.
I mean, if this doesn't justify mass rallies
at urban centers, I really don't know what
does don't these members of Congress and senators
work for us?
And of course, that's true in theory.
It's true on paper.
In reality, they're mostly serving the interests
of big corporations.
How disconnected from reality do you have
to be to think that six hundred dollars after
seven months of nothing is going to solve
a problem and stimulate the economy?
It's completely it's magical, delusional thinking